what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesomeness inside
you explode out into the world so you
can do something crazy special now to
help you in your journey today we're
going to talk about how to attract
corporate sponsors and brand deals so a
question I get asked by a lot of
entrepreneurs especially ones who are
trying to become digital influencers is
how do I attract hope for brands and
sponsors how do I get the brand deals
how do I get the money from the
corporations to sponsor my content
sponsor what I'm creating to have a big
impact and so I'm gonna share with you
today my 7 ways to do it I've had some
success using these on a1 to share them
with you so you can hopefully grow your
business to number one is produce great
work and this is by far the most
important one this is the one that sucks
to hear because you want an easier
answer because this is hard to produce
great work and be consistent at it is
really really really really really hard
and it's grinding and every day making
tweaks but a lot of the biggest brain
deals that I've gotten all the
successful brand deals that I've gotten
people have come to me I've tried
outreach to different brands I've had my
agent outreach in different brains it's
never worked out for all the best
corporate deals brand deals that I've
had for anything in my business whether
it's my website whether it's my youtube
channel or the social media speaking
gigs it's all been from people finding
me and it's because I produce a lot of
consistent great content and I'm known
in my industry and so that that becomes
really important so before you go out
and start reaching out to brands the
danger here is you spend so much time
trying to reach out the brains that you
don't spend enough time actually
building your business it's a danger in
funding to like I need startup capital
for my company you spend so much time
trying to raise capital that you don't
spend enough time actually building the
business and if you build a business
it's easier to attract startup capital
right and so the more time you spend on
actually creating great stuff and not
just for youtubers if you look at people
have gotten other brand deals people
have been a sponsored content people are
asked to join in on adidas commercials
or
or be a spokesperson for a company it
always comes because they've already
done a lot of great work there are known
quantity right and so are you unknown
quantity have you done enough great work
that people start finding you at any of
these companies they have people whose
job it is to know who the people are in
the industry who are influencers any big
company that you work with so any big
giant corporation that you're hoping to
get sponsoring your content what you're
doing your business they have people
whose job it is to find influencers like
you to find businesses like you people
to work with are you standing out enough
are you on their radar enough are you
producing enough great work to get
noticed and if you do that you're in a
much better position because people are
coming to you so the win is you're
spending time on the work that you love
you're making better content and you
have people coming to you which gives
you a huge advantage as opposed to you
trying to creat yourself out to
companies when your audience is not as
big yet you're not spending as much time
working on your content because you're
spending time pitching and it puts them
in the driver's seat because you're
coming to that instead of them coming to
you
so produce great work consistently it's
the most boring one on this list and the
most important as well okay so number
two is have a clear mission and message
people want to know what you stand for
people want to know who they're buying
into so as an example I believe in
entrepreneurs it comes out and
everything that I create right I have my
one word to believe I have I have my
message of helping entrepreneurs and so
the brains that come to me are the ones
who like my message they want to help
believe in people as well as an
inspirational aspirational message it's
clearly defined some companies think
that's stupid great like we're not going
to work together and get along anyway
and some companies love that so you need
to be able to quickly if I come to your
video I know what you stand for I know
what you're about if it's confusing if I
don't know what you're about then you're
just one of many other people that I
could potentially sponsor as a company
where I want the people who are clearly
aligned with the mission and direction
of my business
[Music]
number three is have a defined target
audience you want to make sure that your
audience matches up with the audience of
a brand that you're gonna work with
right the brand's who want to hire you
are gonna be the ones who have a similar
audience overlay with you so I help
entrepreneurs if you want to target
entrepreneurs you want to understand
entrepreneurs you want feedback to
entrepreneurs
I'm one of the best people in the world
to work with if you want to do anything
else I'm not right if you want to sell
lipstick or you want to sell this new
video game or you want feedback from you
know a different demographic it's not
gonna be me don't talk to me I can't
help you even if I love your thing and I
want to help you I can't give you as
good feedback or reception as somebody
else and that's important like you want
to be one of the best in the world at
this audience and so anybody who wants
to target that audience will want to
come to you first and ignore everybody
else and so you can start really niche
and then build your base out so
entrepreneurship is a big base right you
can go more niche if you wanted to
target entrepreneurs I would start with
like tech entrepreneurs or fashion
entrepreneurs or food entrepreneurs
right and so whatever you're really
passionate about target that group and
then you can build out from there but
there are people who want to target tech
entrepreneurs and there's people who
want to target fashion entrepreneurs and
so you want to be the number one person
for that niche and if you're number one
or number two three like you're at the
top of the list somewhere you can also
charge a much higher rate because if
they wanted to only target fashion
entrepreneurs sure they can come to me
I'm gonna charge him a lot of money
because they reach a lot of people but I
can't really help them target only
fashion entrepreneurs that's where you
can come in and so you can make a lot
more money even with a smaller audience
because it's really niche focused and
targeted and so it starts with thinking
about who do you want to reach iku do
you relate to the most what what
combination of interests so not just
entrepreneurship but also fashion right
like pick the things that you love the
two or three things that make you tick
the people who were just that's your jam
you love these people you're one of them
and mix those together and that's your
new demographic your new target audience
and then as you build more reputation
more content more experience you can
slowly build out and it happens over and
over and over and over and over again
right Facebook started just being in
college dorm rooms
and then building out to a huge company
right Tesla started just selling their
sports cars and the high-end cars and
now they're coming in to be mass-market
you don't start by going wide successful
companies often start with one little
niche audience making it amazing and
then expanding and expanding and
expanding and expanding we number four
is work with other brands what a brain
wants to see is that they're not the
first brand like you've done other deals
with other corporate sponsors other
brains and so even if you have to do
spec work demo work as an example for
company free work just to show what you
can do it may not make you money the
first time but to have a demo to say hey
look here's something that we did with
whatever company we could do something
for you and you charge that company
nothing just be able to use their name
being able to say that you've worked
with a brain especially there have a
bigger name of some sort it helps you
get other deals so at an example I even
look at Lily who we have the unlock in
Lily series with it's an entrepreneur
that I'm helping coach her to become a
professional speaker she got her first
TED talk that was one of the like
checkmarks like we want to have you have
a TED talk she first won in Illinois I
believe and so now we can use that like
Lily's done a TED talk it adds
credibility if she's gonna go do a
speaking gig somewhere else she's
already done her TED talk and so you
want the same thing for your business
find any brand like maybe maybe your
friend is a banker and maybe you can
work with their small division at Bank
of America and create some little tiny
campaign for them that hopefully get
some results and it's free but you get
to use a Bank of America name now I said
I work with Bank of America even though
it was only this one little chapter
you've worked with Bank of America
putting that logo hiding that
credibility gives you so much more than
the other people in your industry and
you usually find some small way to get
started some tiny small deal some branch
some offshoot of the company but then
you can leverage their name to go out
and get paid bigger deals because nobody
wants to be the first a lot of brands
don't want to be the first they want to
know that you've done this before that
your experience that you have a track
record and so having some kind of demo
just show them again even if you did
free work really makes a difference when
you're lining up for
Steele way number five is actually a
customer this is my own personal policy
but I only like doing deals with
companies that I use and I support like
if I'm telling you to go out and check
out this product to use this company
I've used them myself I vetted them I
would hate to feel like I've recommended
a company that then they let you guys
down with service and like well you know
what they paid me so it doesn't really
matter like I I really value their
relationship with you guys and I think
it's important for you with your
audience the same thing your customers
you want to recommend products that you
actually believe in not just because of
getting the paycheck and actually turn
away most deals because they just want
me to pitch their thing they're not
really bringing value to the audience
and I haven't used their stuff and they
don't even care if I use their stuff
like this is not right
people and so when I did deals with Sage
right sage is one of my clients and we
have a three year deal together and I
use sage in my business as my accounting
software company free here trying to
dance salsa we use sage and I'm a happy
customer and you know I did deals with
Aweber and I use Aweber I've been in
Aweber customer for newsletters for ten
years I can speak about their products
we use it every week in my business and
so if it's a new brand that's coming on
board I had two companies email me this
week saying hey we'd like to do a deal
with you
like well step one is I need to actually
use your product and see if I'm
comfortable using it and using it in my
business and would be okay recommending
it to other people most brands see that
as a positive most brands want to work
with people who actually can talk
intelligently about their products and
actually use their products and actually
care and it's helped separate you from
the other creators from the other you
know people you're competing against for
dollars because they're not always
asking for it because they're saying
yeah we'll pay check great I'll take it
or you actually care about recommending
good products so if you're an actual
customer it makes it way easier to open
the relationship when we're talking with
Aweber as an example
I know a weber I know the company I've
been using you guys for 10 years it just
makes it so much easier and so if you're
following them on social media as an
example you could follow them you could
retweet their things you can get
involved with them you can reply to
their snaps you can
YouTube videos they check you out now
you're on their radar you're an actual
customer you use their stuff like you
want to find ways to get on their radar
so they know about you and it's much
easier when you're a customer you can
actually talk about it number six is
have clear contact information you'd be
surprised at how difficult it can be
sometimes to reach out to people you
know on your social media profiles
however people are consuming you on your
website it should be easy to find a way
to reach you whether it's an email form
whether you're listing your email
address whether you know you want them
to tweet you like have an easy way for
people to reach out to you because so
often people will look at the contact
page you don't see anything or the email
address is hidden or they rely on
sending messages like YouTube's
YouTube's really bad at this because you
have a send YouTube message where a lot
of people don't see their YouTube
messages they all turn notifications on
so make sure there's an easy way to
reach you that brains can reach out if
there's a contact person whether it's
you or someone on your team here's how I
can get in touch because if it's hard to
figure out how to get in touch with you
then they're not going to get in touch
with you it seems like a really basic
thing but for a lot of people who have
sizable audiences who could actually get
big brand deals you don't know how to
reach them and that creates a big
problem
[Music]
and we number seven is don't try to
convince them I hate trying to convince
people of things that they don't want to
do so a couple examples I find a lot of
brains just want to sell something right
they just want to sell your sell their
stuff to your audience
and I don't want to convince them that
that's the wrong method like you're in
direct marketing which is we just want
to make sales from your channel look
that's not what I'm about I'm not I'm
not your sales guy I'm happy to help
transfer some some branding and some
goodwill and say hey here's a good
company that I use and recommend I'm not
gonna say you guys need to go and buy
this thing right now it's the best thing
ever and I take a 10% commission right
it's not how I roll other people roll
like that and that's fine I don't want
to try to convince them that what
they're doing is wrong because it's just
too much of a battle or even worse as a
brand that's not currently advertising
on social media they're not currently
working with influencers they're not
currently sponsoring anybody to try to
convince somebody like if you're a
charity and you're trying to convince a
sponsor to give you money and they've
never done any charity sponsorship
before it's just so hard you're gonna
get tiny dollars if anything because
it's just not on their radar
it's way easier to go to a company
that's already doing sponsor content and
find a way to be better than the other
people that they're sponsoring so if
you're a charity like how can be better
than the other charities how can you
give that poor company more value than
the other charities currently are
because they already understand giving
the charities works
it feeds what we're trying to do as part
of our business model so you don't have
to any that education it's way better if
you're trying to get dollars for your
YouTube channel if people are already
paying YouTube influencers you just do a
better job than the other YouTube
influencers which isn't honestly that
hard to do but most YouTube users aren't
great at it so you just do better than
them and try to convince a corporation
to get on YouTube in the first place
it's too much of a battle and so I hate
spending time with customers who don't
see the value it's just too much work
and it's just this is business this
isn't just how to get brand deals now in
sponsorship stop trying to convince
customers to work with you if they don't
understand the value of working with you
it's like great you don't understand no
problem move on to the next person who
gets it it's much better to spend time
with ideal clients who understand your
value proposition and love it and I want
to work with you then the to waste time
on trying to convince somebody and
slowly drag
along it's just a great rule to follow
in business one last bonus tip that I
want to share this coming in mind tip
number eight or bonus tip is try to sell
an annual program too many times brands
come in and they want to do a quick deal
like hey let's do a test deal let's do
one thing as a test and it's really hard
to make that pay off it's hard because
you're introducing a brand to an
audience and especially when you're not
doing like a sales pitch when you're not
doing direct marketing it takes time for
them to get used to this company that
you bring it on board and so anytime a
company comes to me and wants to do like
a one-off test I say I start at annual
programs here's how I started like
here's how much it cost at a minimum and
it's for a year so like like one video a
month for a year a video every two
months for a year it's always an annual
program and some companies don't want to
jump on that it's just too much work
it's too much work to get to know the
company to do the setup all the
administer invoicing all that stuff but
building a relationship is too much work
to then have it do one video it doesn't
work out as what they expected they
didn't actually get a lot of momentum
built up because you're only doing one
video and then you're stuck the next
month trying to find another corporate
branding partnership and so I always
always always always always push for
doing an annual deal where you are the
expert you're helping guide the process
you know what works for your audience
instead of doing these one-off little
tiny small start-stop stacks so that's
my take on the seven ways plus one bonus
to attract corporate sponsors and brand
deals
I made this beauty because Margot
escargots asked me to if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover in a future seven
ways video check out the link in the
description you can go and cast your
vote I'd also love to know is there an
eight nine ten you want to add to the
list and what was your favorite from the
seven that I listed share your thoughts
leave in the comments I look forward to
hearing what you have to say I also want
to give a quick charta to say czar
Bonilla say czar thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word taking that picture posting to
Twitter I really really really
appreciate it and I'm so glad you
enjoyed the block so thank you again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
what what signals one was volume you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details